I did hear a dog bark,
while you were speaking,
so eloquently in the background.
Yeah, yeah, that was Bo.
Yeah, okay, well I just
He doesn't know that I'm on a podcast.
You didn't explain?
You didn't explain to Bo that -
I did, no, I did.
In fact, I had someone give
him meat to take him away.
(laughing)
Then he's like right up
under my feet breathing,
he breathes heavy, he's
just such a heavy breather.
(laughing)
And then it's all these plugs.
I'm like, you're gonna unplug everything.
(laughing)
You know, I wish you had,
I'm guessing that you probably
put someone in charge of
keeping an eye on Bo, during.
I thought I did.
You know what I say to that?
Thanks, Obama.
(laughing)
I know just who to blame.